as you get better let's just put it that
way as you get better as you improve as
your openings evolve you begin to start
thinking about strategic plans combined
with your opening ideas so first of all
I would like to ask how many of you are
efore players 1e 4 and 1 d 4 players and
how many of you just play both
University ok that's power to you who
can do that when I was starting to play
chess essentially I didn't have so much
strategic ideas as so much as I was
responding to tactics you know like my
opponent would make a tactical
possibility I saw a trap I would avoid
it and so forth and so on
and I didn't really understand strategic
play and certainly I didn't understand
the idea of combining a strategic plan
with the opening I chose so in other
words let's say I played 1.e4 and if my
opponent answered income 1e5 I went
after the guy on f7 and you know
checkmate and if I didn't check my
opponent on f7 I probably lost but that
was like my feeling about efore that
after E 5 I could go after my opponent's
pawn so that was basically my strategic
understanding of chess which wasn't very
good and as I kept playing as a religion
efore why I say is a religion well
because I was told Bobby Fischer said II
for one efore best by test great so I
wanted to play like Bobby Fischer
unfortunately just seemed like everybody
and his brother had a special defense to
1.e4 so if I played e4 and they played a
Sicilian and I was expected to know
the night or the dragon the classical
Sicilian arouse errs fashiona coughs I
mean all kinds of things and if I play E
for and they played the Alekhine I was
expected to know you know the four pawns
attack and everything so all of that
chess theory that I had to learn just
basically drove me away from 1/4 so ok
so I went to d4 well I wasn't much
better either because then everybody had
a specialist defense to one before they
played an Enzo Queens gambit declined a
benoni of Benko gambit even sometimes
budapest so I thought well ok I'll keep
going here all the way over to the edge
of the board and I started playing 1 c4
ok so again it wasn't like I had some
vast strategic ideas about my opening it
was just that I was trying to avoid
losing or getting a worse position or
than 10 12 15 moves whatever so c4
started to become a favor and somehow in
my mind I began to think that one move
was connected with another there was a
connection with my moves so what was I
trying with c4 well one of the things I
was trying to do was to build a fortress
I was trying to play Knight f3 g3 Bishop
g2 castles Knight c3 and just have a
save King and I wouldn't get checkmated
either on f2 or an f7 ok but then I
started thinking that ok well one c4
protects the d5 square and it wouldn't
be great if for example my opponents
were to play c5 g3
g6 Bishop g2 Bishop g7 Knight c3 aha
this is very interesting I'm controlling
the square d5 uh-huh I have a
strategical plan of controlling the
square d5 that's cool and let's just say
my opponent continued in the same manner
knight c6 okay so so far is everything's
okay and I thought okay I've got this
Bishop on g2 it makes a very nice
impression going all the way down the
long diagonal how can I improve that
bishop and I got to thinking that well
one of the ways I could do that one of
the ways I could improve this Bishop is
to get rid of this Knight
so I started thinking okay let me play
a3 and what's my idea okay let's say
let's suppose my opponent would play a
six
I play route b1 now we can see the
makings of my idea my idea is that
strategically I want to play b4 force a
swap and then I want to play b5 and to
create try to create a targeted weakness
here on the b7 pawn okay let's go back
for a moment and let's try something
else
let me try c4 and give my opponent a
different approach let's say my opponent
would play e5 okay I would play g3 my
opponent for argument's sake would play
knight c6 Bishop g2 let's say my
opponent would play g6 PI Knight c3
Bishop g7 and now rook b1 okay so I'm
thinking that you know I've got this
diagonal I got the potential of
establishing an outpost for my knight I
like that very much
I want to play b4 b5 and open the
diagonal so a lot of my opponents would
play for argument's sake let's say d6 or
even let's say a 5 let's give them a 5 I
play a 3 let's give them d6 I would play
bihar --tags --tags let's give them f5
let me kick night let's I play here
let's say they play here and say I play
here Castle and this was a very standard
position that I would reach and I got to
play more and more games like this where
I was literally using move 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8
all all based on a strategic plan of
occupying this diagonal sometimes in
this type of position I would play Queen
b3 and c5 check b6 trying to create
weaknesses here sometimes I would play
91 night c2 night before you know if I
could get established the d5 outpost
sometimes I would play Bishop g5 to a
limit that eliminate this Knight so once
again I could establish as outpost so
suddenly I was starting to play with
strategic ideas literally from one move
one throughout the game the following
game and I'm going to ask - ask
yourselves to choose an opening where we
can talk about a strategic idea that
really develops from move one in this
game which was played in 1979 oh my
goodness
I was playing grandmaster tony miles and
Tony
at that time was really the leader of
British chess in the UK I should say and
he became one at the top grandmasters in
the world and one of the first
grandmasters of the UK I think he was
the first aha
and he led a whole slew of grandmasters
from dr. John nan Jonathan mess tell
Jonathan Spielman Raymond Keene later
came Nigel short later after him after
Nigel short came Micky Adams and so on
now the strange thing about Tony at this
time
Tony had a universal answer for every
opening move whether you played efore
d4c for he played B 6 play B 6
he's just playing B 6 on move 1 against
everything and doing incredibly well one
of them you will recall us that he beat
anatoly karpov I think with E for a six
call if I defy the improvement of B 6 as
they get the advanced pawn to b5 anyway
so we're setting up for the game the
organizer whatever is doing his
telephone thing you know his mic thing
everybody get ready and you know the
Gong sounds and I realize that I'm going
to be facing B 6 and you know my
strategic insight and the de-stress
opening is going to be messed up by the
sky's move 1 B 6 so I play GP so I just
finished playing G 3 pressing the clock
writing down my move and Tony whis leans
across the board
and he whispers I love these moral
victories ok man you know like your beat
no world with these
pigs I'm not standing in line you know
so he thinks for a minute or two and he
pops out with E 5 well quick as a flash
I knew what to do and now I had my
English and I got my strategic concepts
so c4 g3 now certainly what I was doing
to people this whole night see three
bishops you two calmly just developing
my pieces and then strategically looking
to expand on the queenside and control
the centre was not lost on Tony miles so
he tried to trick me by taking me out of
my eye I took him out of his comfort
zone on move one on move - he tries to
take me out of mine and we get this
position well here I can't do my Knight
c3 rugby one routine and I mean Knight
c3 he's just going to if I go Knight c3
attacking his pawn he's simply going to
advance it so I had to be flexible and
to change my strategy so in this
position so at this time as black
I played several openings including the
coral Khan and including the French so I
took some of my experience from those
defenses and applied it to my approach
in this position I figured I should
attack his pawn with d4 and I was
thinking that if he were to capture my
pawn besides it the fact that I could
simply recapture with the Queen I a
variation I would play Knight hear
Knight to f3 and I transpose into a kind
of a choral composition where actually
I've just got an extra move and after I
recapture this pawn with my knight we'll
have an isolated queen pawn position I
was perfectly happy playing against
that and if he played efore which was
his choice then we kind of get a French
defense type of structure and in a
normal French my pawn would be on e3 and
my bishop would be blocked but this
isn't a normal French in fact my bishop
isn't blocked at all this one is so I've
got to figure out a way of breaking him
out I play to f3 okay so now if black
was to capture on f3
I would recapture with a knight might be
very very happy because and I talk about
this a lot and I do this consciously I
do this consciously I actually verbalize
internally to myself at the chessboard I
do a running count in my head of the
number of units that are not on their
original squares so the way I would say
is that in this position White's much
better why because he's ahead in the
time count or rather White has more
development strictly speaking I would go
one two three four four two one I've
I've developed my army faster than my
opponent who has almost everything on
the original square except except for
the pawn on d5 so I would say I have a
huge advantage and the reason for that
is because black is basically pushed his
pawn once twice and played three moves
with his pawn so I would really have
been happy if Tony had captured on f3 he
played f5 which is the natural follow-up
to his previous play strategically
speaking he's trying to keep this
outpost upon me he's trying to keep his
pawn on e4
to discourage my development of the
night okay so here we have to think
about the position from a strategic
point of view because that's the nature
of the class to think of strategy these
pawns make a nice impression and we
shouldn't overlook that fad they do make
a nice impression but your job is to
look at your Trump's okay so since
you're playing the side of the good guy
here that's me what are the Trump's or
put another way what is the downside of
black structure anybody care to tell me
sir and when the pawns are so advanced
that could be good but it could be bad
so they leave weak squares in their wake
right they're weak black squares and
specifically this square this square is
a very weak square we can imagine if we
could post a knight there not only would
it be attacking this pawn but it
wouldn't be very easy for black to get
rid of at night
okay so immediately we start to imagine
a strategy we could bring our Knight to
c3 we could bring our Queen to b3 we
could bring our Knight to h3 and f4 ah
we've got a problem
the moment we bring our Knight to f4
what's the drawback of having the knight
on f4 from whites point of view what
would be a draw if I could take that
night and just lift it up and stick it
on f4 what would be the drawback of the
night on f4
not much of a drawback I agree but maybe
the view of the bishop on c1 would say
hey you know like maybe you forgot about
me ah so we start to think again okay
because we want all of our pieces good
all of the time so you might start to
think I understand we're going to go
Knights III Queen b3 provoked the knight
to f6 play our Bishop to g5 then stick
our knight on f4 right so we get the
bishop in front of the night a knight is
going to be on f4 is going to be
wonderful okay so we continue Knight H
396 castles there were other moves
Bishop e7 notice that with this move
Bishop e7 it's a kind of a strange
little move like what's up with that
Bishop e7 well here
tony was reluctant to allow me after the
normal-looking Knight f6 to allow me to
simply allow the pin so he's being coy
plays Bishop d7 that's fine Knight c3
was it really any better move Knight f6
Bishop g5 Bishop e6 Knight here bishop
here and we can see that black is
defending his d5 pawn as best he can and
as long as he can maintain this pawn on
e4 he's going to be happy okay so here
again now we have to switch our
strategic thinking I mean our my plan
had been to put as much pressure on d5
as possible I can see that in the near
future my opponent is going to play h6
Bishop takes Bishop takes will be forced
then my pawn on d4 is going to be
weakened I'm going to be obliged to play
- III so I play III at once
recording castles and now ah in a funny
sense I've kind of hit a wall right like
I've done basically the best I can and
if I continue with a move for example
like Bishop takes f6 Bishop takes f6
Queen b3 attacking this pawn on d5 well
he can chase my queen away for one thing
with the move Knight a5 if he doesn't
have anything better so I need to change
strategic plans any suggestions
I mean yeah rugby 1.d4 d5 yeah a3 okay
but I'm I'm a little bit slow we can
imagine that for example after a three
age six bishop takes f6 Bishop takes f6
b4 I am setting up for Queen b3 type of
move but with his bishop on the f6
square he can defend d5 once more with
the move Knight e7 so one of the things
that we need to do when we think
strategically when we're good enough to
start to stop just thinking about
tactics tactics tactics but we think
strategically one of the things we
constantly have to do is talk to our
pieces how you doing okay how you doing
okay okay not so okay not so okay okay
okay not so okay Bishop on g2 is blocked
so I take take sorry I want to explain
this for a moment so my idea is that
this bishop on g2 needs a new outlook on
life
and I'm thinking that because I've
chased my bishop my opponent's Bishop
back to the f7 square it's going to pop
out on h3 I'll attack this pawn or after
I exchange I'll attack the square e six
so I traded anticipating that if my
opponent were to recapture with his F
pawn I would improve my bishop which is
block so from Tony's point of view he
said okay well I'm not going to allow
you a good Bishop and I'm going to
improve mine Bishop
f7 now has a longer reach bishop g6 okay
so again what kind of thing should I be
doing now suggestions from the class
does anybody like the advance d5 if you
don't know don't don't all shout out
well once if you like the advance of you
I didn't like the advance d5 for the
very simple reason that after the night
jumps to e5 thanks to the pawn on e4
he's got two beautiful outpost potential
outpost for his knight so the move d5
actually sucks
that's a terrible move he would just
jump to the center and he'd be very
happy on the other hand I'm very unhappy
about my opponent structure this looks
like a beautiful pawn chain from h7 to
g6 and I think I need to break up
Black's team so I played the move g3 g4
to break up the team so I'm thinking in
my mind's eye that after some trades
happen I'll end up if I can if I could
just take this pawn f5 off the board and
take this pawn g4 off the board I'll end
up controlling be six and that will be
very good for me so takes takes I should
explain what's going on here so I took
on f6 with the idea that if he
recaptures with the bishop I wanted to
play Queen takes g4 and his pawn on e4
is weak maybe I would step back once
Julian
I beg your pardon
Bishop takes F let's have a quick look
okay so I I play G for Julia makes a
very sensible ask a very sensible
question what about tags takes and now G
for so the idea is that by playing in
this fashion I've reduced my opponents
options right well one of the things I
was worried about was a kind of a peace
sacrifice that let me see if I can
reconstruct my thoughts for a moment so
let's imagine a peace sacrifice that
would go like say like this takes takes
takes takes and let's say I go into the
corner and let's say he takes my knight
I take and he goes something like this
okay so let's say my knight moves
somewhere I can go to h5 I can go to g2
I can go to e2 let's just for the moment
say Knight eetu and let's imagine this
and I probably this is good for me but
just at the time I had this kind of
weird feeling that maybe just maybe this
was actually pretty good for him I saw
my mind's eye that maybe black could
play moves like Queen d5 or possibly
Bishop d5 and it was going to be very
awkward for me to play Bishop g2 in the
face of f3 so maybe this is a good
sacrifice is a good position for me but
that at least is the reason why I didn't
fight Bishop f6 I didn't want to give
him that possibility and maybe it's not
good for and
but it's a good question Bhaiji for he
took I took and again at this point I'm
very hopeful that this pawn on e4 is
going to be very wheat that I'm just
going to play Queen takes G for Bishop
g2 and collect he took on h3 I took on
e7 you took on e7 i play queen g4 okay
so kind of funny things are going on I'm
not a hundred percent too sure but I
like I like the way the situation so the
I like the situation as it exists in
some cases he has to be a little bit
careful that I don't play a move like
Knight d5 and end up occupying f6 in
other cases he has to be a little
careful that I don't play moves like
Knight takes h3 Knight g5 and simply
slurp the pawn on e4 let's see what he
played he played Bishop c4 attacking my
rook like rook f2 he played rook f5 with
a very dangerous threat of rook g5
let's say that was a visual I got a
visual impression of the rook on g5 I
didn't like it one bit
I played Knight takes h3 to defend
against rook g5 he played rook h5 and
now his idea is pretty clear he wants to
play Bishop to e6 and slurped my knight
if my knight were to move he's going to
play rook to g5 now the game is stopped
being strategical okay now it's it's
damn tactical and what do you think I
did
I'll give you a clue I his threat
one of it one of the threats I have to
deal with is a future rook g5 and I want
to pre stop rook G Phi for good as a
threat
so let's just consider what I can do we
understand that Bishop e6 should scare
the bejesus out of us right so if I move
my Queen for example to g3
then for example after Bishop e6 Knight
comes to f4 rook g5 thank you very much
I lose the game so it's certainly not a
queen move if I play Knight takes e4
Bishop e6 is going to cost me a piece so
that's just not very good Julian yes yes
Knight f6 check Queen takes
if I take the queen he'll take my queen
oopsy-daisy I lost a piece okay let's
have a quick look-see Knight takes e4
oops
yeah Bishop e6 and again if I play
Knight f6 check possibly he can just
move his king but I was thinking this
was quite simple Queen takes I can take
his rook but he'll take my rook with a
check if we trade oops sorry
oops I don't mean to do do that if I
take his Queen he will take mine and I'm
simply a piece down okay I have a pawn
or something for it but it won't be
sufficient compensation so unfortunately
I showed you the move I played I played
whip g2 so this is a very nice move
because first of all it covers any
future ideas of rope g5 but it does so
with the tempo I am now threatening to
capture his rook Queen takes h5 thanks
to the pin on the G file rook h4 this
move is intended to defend the pawn on
e4 Queen g3 rook f8 we have a very big
threat of course playing rook to f3 so
what do I do now
9fr is an excellent move Knight f4 is an
excellent move just get is blocking his
rook from coming to f3 but but here I
started to get a little greedy in my
mind's eye I sure wanted to win this
pawn on e4 and Knight g5 that's an
that's a pretty nasty tempo against his
rook on h4 so he played rook h5 yeah
okay so what I did what did I do now
well one thing I would really like to do
is simply take this pawn if I take this
pawn with the knight on c3 I have a
slight problem that after Bishop to d5 I
may have some regrets about my rook on
g2 if I take with the other night also
very very excellent move the advantages
of taking with this other nighters I
thought after Knight takes bishop d5 at
least I have this move Knight takes d5
so maybe I should take the pawn on e4
Julie have a good idea for right here
pardon me you want to play d5 and
possibly take one day
well here I had a more greedy thought
yeah that was my greedy thought my
greedy thought is that this bishop is
actually kind of weird on the one hand
it controls the square f1 which is kind
of regrettable and I definitely don't
want to get checkmated by an idea like
Queen here and Queen here on the other
hand this Square d5 would be very
attractive imagine my knight could jump
to d5 and then jump to f4
well that rook would really be rather
ugly so I began to think that perhaps
just perhaps that the bishop on c4 was
overloaded so I said why don't you move
your Bishop Tony please find a better
square for your Bishop b3 he moved his
Bishop to d3 protecting his knight so
now I have given up my ambition of
capturing this pawn instead I decided
that I had a higher calling and trying
to Cole that rook went 95 Queen d7
Knight f4
give me the rock you played rook h6 and
I played rook d1 the idea of rook d1
isn't that I am not really that
interested in and winning upon actually
it's not true I'm always interested in
winning upon but I really wanted to step
side step any tactic of Knight takes d4
eat XD for Queen takes d4 with a very
unfortunate check so I chose the square
d1 to get out of the tactic but at the
same time to perhaps
worry him that I might one day when upon
rook a5 and this is actually a very fine
move I believe I played at this moment
h4 this really pounds home the problem
that black is having remember how that
rook when it went to f5 and then it went
to h5 was so threatening and scary and
powerful has suddenly become this neat
little mouse that is trapped on this
horrible square h6 and it has no further
role in the game so here I was really
starting to think that Oh life is
getting very very good not just for
ideas like Knight h7 and Knight g6 but
other ideas like Knight g6 and Queen
check sometimes combined refine or put
it another way imagine that my night
this night on f4 goes to e6 this Knight
goes backwards for a bad reason and I
get to go Queen b8 check so things were
really looking good
another idea from White's point of view
is if I can also bring this night on g5
to e6 sometimes I can go h5 and even I
can end up sacrificing my queen
perhaps on the square g6 so
unfortunately from blacks point of view
black is almost now in a strategic
strategically speaking in a stranglehold
he's been completely outdone and threats
galore all over the board
he played Knight takes d4 which was a
desperate attempt check King h2 Queen B
five so here he has some kinds of funny
tricks not too sure what exactly they
are based on various pins so like you
know if I take here that maybe he could
take with a check but I had a very good
move here that just cemented everything
Knight h3 and again this horrible
situation with his rook on h6 I could
now be threatening to capture on d3 and
sometimes I'm even threatening to play
h5 he played Queen f6
I played h5 he released and I played
here did he resign I'm not sure just a
second no I think you played g5 okay
here I have a pretty simple win rook
comes here so my idea is as simple as if
he takes my knight I want to take with
Czech followed by Knight f4 and if he
allows me I want to take on f5 followed
by rook d5 and capture this pawn on g5
rook takes rook takes
check night g2 rook takes rook takes
resigns
strategic strategic play strategic ideas